notre série de portraits avoir 20 ans
dans les années 2020 je vous propose ce
midi de partir à la rencontre de merlin
gauthier un jeune militant écologiste il
se bat notamment pour sauver la forêt de
monthoux leur en plein coeur du morvan
portraits signés bamba guèye et marianne
cazaux
c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir 20 en 2020
c'est
bonjour je m'appelle merlin gauthier
j'ai 21 ans je suis militant écolo j'ai
passé une partie de mon enfance à
chanteloup mis dans la nièvre et je fais
un master d'études environnementales
[Musique]
mon engagement il est né je devais avoir
16 17 ans j'allais passer le bac et
c'est face à la contradiction entre mes
cours qui me disait il n'ya pas de
problème à arrêter de polluer et la
réalité qui me disait ben en fait on
continue à polluer
le 6 novembre ya eu une manifestation
qui a rassemblé 600 personnes pour dire
l'attachement qu'on a ici à la forêt du
mont couleurs on est contre le fait qu'
il ya des coupes rases à l'intérieur de
cette forêt qui est un patrimoine
écologique mais aussi un paysage
extraordinaire
mois le dernier truc que j'ai fait
c'était à aubervilliers ou des jardins
étaient menacés de faim ont été détruits
pour construire une piscine et jardin
ouvrier qui servait à l'alimentation des
gens et du coup on a fait une manif moi
j'ai fait une discours pour dénoncer ça
[Musique]
bienvenue nous sommes dans une zone
natura 2000 comme vous pouvez le
constater la nature est préservée enfin
du cynisme évidemment comme c'est les
propriétaires fonciers qui ont le droit
de faire ce qu'ils veulent de leur
parcelle est bien en réalité le parc n'a
aucune possibilité d'empêcher ce genre
de ravages nous sommes dans une coupe
rase c'est à dire que toutes les
essences d'arbres peupliers à être
boulot chênes châtaigniers
tout ça ça a été rasé ça c'est notre
héritage on va leur donner cet héritage
qui va être complètement mais
catastrophiques pour le futur
toute ma vie je vais être obligé et tous
les gens qui sont ma génération de se
battre contre la destruction et surtout
les conséquences des descriptions des
siècles passés
c'est dur d'avoir 20 ans c'est dur dans
le sens où on est confronté à une
réalité qui est implacable
[Musique]
ce matin dans le morvan tout était gelé
c'est un oui c'était très beau
d'ailleurs il y avait du brouillard
évidemment des tout-petits et aimait
bien peut-être qu'il a pris s'appuie
dans nos racines
il l'aimé beaucoup et de hors
jeu s'amuser dans les pieds avec
faisait du
il me dit mme au lycée mais pierre dans
le jardin de ma grand mère c'était mon
refuge et j'ai toujours eu une affection
énorme pour les les espaces calme
riche de d'arbres de fleurs de rivières
parce que c'était des endroits où on
emmerde et pas et où je pouvais rêver
rêver d'autre chose que de la vie
quotidienne et sert à
ça c'est une carte des sites industriels
et sites seveso de france que j'ai fait
moi-même pour l'association notre maison
brûle qui donc est une association de
surveillance des sites industriels
on a tous notre part à faire et moi j'ai
une part presque
aussi importante que les autres et comme
j'ai plus de temps plus de moyens plus
d'éducation etc moins de problèmes eh
ben je dois mettre les bouchées doubles
dans 20 ans j'aimerais me dire que il y
aura plus à se battre parce qu'on aura
gagné et je pourrais être dans mon
jardin à écrire des livres parce que moi
c'est ce que j'aimerais faire mais je
vais pas mentir j'y crois pas je pense
que le combat il sera très long et moi
je pense que dans 20 ans ben je crée
avec des jeunes qui auront vingt ans à
ce moment là et on essaiera de
reconstruire et on continuera de se
battre pour empêcher sa cache y en a
encore
[Musique]